okay so i'm going to take you on an era's tour through relapsed refractory hodgkins but
i promise i'm not going to sing so when we know in the pre-novel era about 70 to 80 percent of
patients were cured with frontline chemotherapy five to ten percent had primary refractory and
about 10 to 20 percent after achieving remission relapsed traditional salvage chemotherapy is
basically platinum-based gemcitabine-based or bendamustine-based and typically resulted in a
two to three year event-free survival of about 60 to 70 percent and patients going into transplant
and complete remission had event-free survivals of 70 to 80 percent and you can see the long-term
disease-free survival curve at the bottom with time post-transplant extending out to 20 years
there's been no randomized studies that have compared salvage regimens and there's only been
one randomized study that has compared salvage regimens and there's only been one randomized
and there's only been one randomized study that has compared salvage regimens and there's only
one randomized study that actually showed the benefit of transplant in hodgkin lymphoma and
that's the mini beam versus meat versus beam that's shown on the right hand side of the panel
so next we're going to hit the brentuximab era so we already heard what how brentuximab works
in the single agent phase two studies in relapse refractory hodgkins particularly predominantly
post-etolica stem cell transplant overall response rates were about 75 percent with about a third of
those being complete remission multiple salvage combinations have been done in combination with
brentuximab and again overall response rates as we've seen 90 percent cr rates as high as 80 percent
and allowing the majority of patients to proceed to transplant with two-year event-free survival
up to 80 percent and and up to 90 percent for the patients going into transplant in cr
this is one study that was a pet adapted sequential study
so two cycles of bv if they achieved pet negativity they went straight to transplant
if they were still pet positive they received two cycles of augmented ice
followed by autologous stem cell transplant 45 patients 12 of them achieved pet negativity after
brentuximab alone of the 33 that were still positive 32 received augmented ice 22 became
negative and of the 45 34 were pet negative prior to transplant and 44 of the 45 were
preceded to transplant you can see the curves on the right hand side and the bottom curve shows
that if you were pet negative going into transplant either with bv alone or after augmented ice you
had an excellent outcome compared to the patients that were still pet positive
this is a smattering of the studies of bv in association with chemotherapy there were too
many studies to fit them all on one slide so i just kind of chose the ones that would that
showed the different regimens and again you can see overall response rates typically 85 to 90 percent
some as high as 100 with pfs around 80 percent and again going into transplant incomplete remission
the pfs were over 90 percent next we hit the pd1 inhibitor era again we know how these agents work
again single agent multiply relapse setting including post-transplant
overall response rate 65 with cr rates of 25 in the keynote 204 study which was pembrolizumab versus
brentuximab we saw a pfs of 13.2 months versus 8.3 months as a single agent and heavily pre-treated
patients checkmate checkmate 205 with nivolumab alone pfs of up to 15.1 months so again um just
an example of a study pd1 based salvage pembro gvd
nevo ice pembro ice again no randomized trials comparing salvage regimens and in this study of
pembro gvd of about 40 patients overall response rate was 100 percent with cr of 95 percent
again this table shows a smattering of the pd1 based salvage regimens the first one is bv with
nevo so no chemotherapy per se first salvage overall response rate of 85 percent with
a cr rate of 67 again patients who went into transplant in complete remission had a two-year
event-free survival of 95 other studies pembro gvd pembro ice nevo ice and another study of
nevo ice in high-risk patients so what can pd1 inhibitor replace transplant we see excellent
results with pd1 inhibitors in patients going to transplant so similar to you know the
btk inhibitors in mantle cell which we'll talk about tomorrow can we get rid of transplant and
then i can retire so pembro maintenance instead of autologous transplant so study in at a memorial
sloan kettering looked at 40 patients they got four cycles of pembro gvd patients in cr then went
on to receive 13 cycles of pembrolizumab maintenance without transplant the overall response rate after
the four cycles of pembro gvd was a hundred percent with a ninety percent cr rate and the
rate 24 24 patients proceeded to pembrolizumab maintenance 10 subsequently progressed and of
those 10 9 went on to receive autologous stem cell transplant the median follow-up with a two-year
progression free survival was 51 so pretty substantially lower than the above 90 percent
that we were seeing if you proceeded to transplant so my answer to that question is not yet so perhaps
you know if you're going to get a transplant you're going to get a transplant you're going to get a
PET is not the best reflection of who can omit transplant and will ctdna be a more sensitive
reflection of the patients that can omit transplant and that remains to be seen in the swag study they
looked at the prognostic value of ctdna 97 percent of patients had detectable ctdna at baseline and
interim ctdna analysis at cycle 3 was prognostic the curves on the bottom show that end of treatment
and that's the the bottom curves so real world data so the initial study was 14 sites across the United States that we started at Mayo Clinic just shy of a thousand patients over about a 10 year period median follow-up was four years and of
the entire cohort the two-year event-free survival was 52 percent with the overall survival of 90 94 percent
this wasn't a very rich checkpoint inhibitor based treatment because we were just it was still in the
early years so of those you can see that only 6.9 percent of patients received checkpoint inhibitor
as part of their salvage regimens the curve that's labeled a shows the event-free survival
based on salvage regimen at any point in time and so you can see the blue line in the top is the checkpoint inhibitor and two-year event-free survival was about 79 percent the middle curve looks at just first salvage so of the almost a thousand patients 649 proceeded to transplant after just one line of salvage and in those in that group if you receive
a checkpoint inhibitor as part of your first salvage the two-year event-free survival was 98 percent versus 69 percent if you received a chemotherapy based salvage and then the brentuximab arms were in the middle and then column E or graph E is the overall survival where the curves are overlapping so no overall survival advantage this is a subsequent study actually the same six academic centers
that you heard from the radiotherapy study 1280 patients over a 12-year period a more pd1 rich
population with 25 percent of patients receiving a pd1 based salvage 28 percent receiving a brentuximab
based salvage and about half receiving a chemotherapy based salvage two-year progression
free survival in the pd1 group shown in the a curve is 88 percent bv 70 percent
and chemotherapy 67 percent again overlapping overall survival curves what was interesting is
even if you achieved a complete remission it mattered how you got to that complete remission
so again in on the right hand side curve a showing the complete metabolic remission if you got there
with a bv sorry if you got there with a checkpoint inhibitor based salvage you had an excellent event
free survival of the patient and you got to that complete remission so again on the right hand side
of about 94 percent and even in if you only achieved a partial metabolic remission you did
better with the checkpoint inhibitor based salvage as opposed to a brentuximab or chemotherapy based
salvage well what if your pd1 refractory what do we do so unfortunately unlike the lymph non-hodgkin
lymphoma and myeloma data CAR-T has had limited success to date in hodgkin lymphoma
the chariot study which looked at autologous cd30 CAR-T and 15 heavily pre-treated patients
although had a very good overall response rate and cr rate what the response duration was quite poor
with only a median progression free survival of 7.1 months and a three-year progression free survival
of 17 percent three other or two other abstracts that were presented at ash looking at an alo nk
with a bispecific cd30 cd16a showed promising results with an overall response rate of 88
percent and a cr rate of almost 60 percent and then a cd25 antibody drug conjugate also promising
at an overall response rate of 70 percent and the cr rate of a third median progression free survival
of nine months allogeneic stem cell transplant although not done very frequently in hodgkin
lymphoma still remains an option for the patient to be able to survive the next three months
and historically has had a three-year progression free survival of up to 40 percent
so these are our practice-based guidelines for salvage therapy and relapse refractory hodgkin
lymphoma if it relapsed or is refractory following abvd then the regimen is typically a pd1 based
salvage regimen either in association with ice or gvd or even in association with brentuximab
relapsed refractory following abvd is typically a pd1 based salvage regimen
following a brentuximab based again a pd1 based regimen if it's relapsed refractory following nevo
avd which is now the standard for advanced stage hodgkin's at least in the united states
kind of depends on when they relapse if it's primary refractory or relapse less than three
months from end of treatment the preferred regimen would be a brentuximab based regimen
and if it's relapsed greater than three months from end of treatment although this is not based
on on studies it's probably not the case if it's relapsed greater than three months from end of
predominantly based on patients who had received single agent pd1 inhibitors in the past and then
subsequently were re-challenged with the same so there is some thought that you can again use a pd1
based regimen either in association with chemotherapy or with brentuximab or a brentuximab
based salvage regimen and then the pet adapted sequential therapy with either bv ice or nevo ice
can be considered for patients with either low disease burden late
relapse older age or increased comorbidities and we hope in the future that we'll see further
studies that allow us to select patients out who don't require autologous stem cell transplant
either with conventional prognostic tools there's an ongoing study at memorial sloan kettering
based on the prior study they took out the stage four patients because those patients seem to have
have had a higher risk of progression and they're randomizing patients to pembrolizumab maintenance
versus autologous stem cell transplant and they're going to be using a pd1 inhibitor
if they achieve a complete remission and then there's other studies that are ongoing based
on ctdna based guided therapy and with that i thank you for your attention